[Music]
all right so again we're gonna do the
Kings gambit part two so what I
originally intended was to do a two part
series but it's been so much fun it's
gonna be a three part series so today we
will approach the main line but we won't
get there we'll be focus mostly on the
Kings gambit declined so as we remember
we get the Kings gambit and we'll go
over two different ways in this position
that black can decline the gambit that
is not to take on f4 and the first one
we'll go over is the classical variation
a Dany Machuca specialty so when he
heard that we were gonna cover this he
had to cancel his lessons but he could
come to class that was very good
so we're gonna go over that and then a
little bit later we'll go over the Falk
beer counter gambit a very aggressive
try by black to unbalance the game and
we'll take a take a look but let's let's
focus first on the classical variation
so Bishop c5 is a very logical move in
this position thank you very much
because after white has played the move
f4 what he's weakened is this diagonal
here
so black puts his Bishop there which can
prevent white and a lot of lines from
castling so that makes a lot of sense
and we'll look at one mistake that's
gonna recur in a lot of these lines one
move that would just be a mistake here
would be to think you can just win this
pawn because I'll ask the audience what
would black play here let's see the
front or the back who knows it
awesome yeah Queen h4 and so this is a
typical mistake you can make when you
move your F pawn is to forget about this
Queen check so this we're gonna have to
look at in every single line because
here okay if you play g3 then you would
you know Lewis lose something here and
okay this also would would be even worse
because now this is checkmate so that'd
be even worse which is why you can't
just take it so you develop your knight
and now black protects this pawn with d6
now if you just go sort of routinely
through the opening here as white all
the show opened all the doors how did
that happen it's scary out there Lulu
what a little out that door it's scary
all right
but if you're a bit too casual here as
white thank you let's just like develop
our pieces to normal squares okay so
this just shows sort of some normal
development that you might play and we
could say black might play Bishop to g4
he might play a six so that white
doesn't play Knight to a4 and white here
should not be better he does have a
little bit more space on the kingside
that's good
but the fact that he can't castle and he
black has really active piece play
should offset you know any advantage
that white has so this isn't the most
testing way from wait to play although
it's definitely a playable option so
more challenging if we go back to his
position here is what moved Danny
Machuca yeah pawn to c3 so this is
showing white just gonna try to play d4
as early as possible and just establish
a huge pawn Center and we'll see what
happens
okay black almost invariably plays
Knight to f6 and white goes through with
his plan pawn to d4 okay
and now after this exchange I have a
question for the class that Danny
Machuca can't answer because he knows it
very well
what should black do in this position so
your Bishop is attacked
so you have two moves you can go back to
b6 or you can play Bishop to b4 which is
check so that's the audience what would
you guys think is the the better move
here because it's already an interesting
decision that black has to make okay and
what's your reasoning okay so you're
hoping yes if white ever castles in the
future that you still have this bishop
on this nice tag no not that diagnol but
OOP this diagonal okay and that is the
main move one reason another reason that
you don't want to play Bishop to b4
check is you're helping white develop
his pieces so after white plays the move
Bishop to d2 and you exchange
you've helped white develop his pieces
your Bishop went to f5 and then to b4
and then to d2 only to help white
develop his Knight and also if you you
know don't play aggressively here's
black if we just make some typical moves
white sort of just has the Center for
free so this should be better for white
in this position and this is the sort of
thing that the white is hoping for so
we'll go back and we'll play Bishop to
b6 which is the main move here and okay
yeah it doesn't make sense just not to
develop as pieces and yeah this is a
relatively nice diagonal for the bishop
so will white be able to blunt that
bishop with this pawn here okay so what
typically happens is they develop and
we'll just look at this position here so
you could just play Bishop to d3 and
castling but white can also try to
immediately play for an advantage here
by playing e5 immediately so in this
position we could take and okay after
the the knight moves Y can play another
aggressive move Bishop to g5 the our
audience just got a lot lower rated so
we lost a lot of rating points okay so
what what should black do here well the
most common move is trading
which does of course help white to
develop his Center but black is hoping
to take advantage of some of these weak
squares so we'll just go a couple a
couple more moves here okay not letting
the knight in to e4 and so black is
hoping in the long run that white is
overextended in the center and he has
there's some sweetnesses there so in the
future he might play moves like Bishop
to g4 and c5 Knight to c6 and attack the
center but White has a lot of attacking
chances in this position there's no
knight on f6 there's this bishop in this
Queen I thought she was gonna leave and
then it was gonna be like a higher
rating class all of a sudden it's very
strange stuff is happening in the back
of the room today okay so yeah so why
just hoping for some good attacking
chances and we'll leave it here this is
sort of the the main position that you
might get something like this which is
why okay the classical is not the most
popular way anymore unless you're
playing against Annie Machuca
then it's okay but we'll go back so
that's a brief introduction into the
classical but the main focus of our
lecture is going to be another
aggressive way to try to turn the tables
on on white so this is a counter gambit
The Fault beer counter gambit and so
instead of white offering upon black
offers upon so he's trying to say I know
you're like an aggressive player cuz
that's why you played the Kings gambit
you want to sack everything
well how about I offer you a pond
instead and almost universally white
takes here and now we're gonna look at
three different moves in this position
it doesn't seem like there's that many
well there's actually quite a lot of
options
the main move is efore so we'll come to
that last but with this move black is
saying okay this is going to be an
annoying pawn in your camp and I'm
preventing you from playing the normal
developing move Knight to f3 and it's
very similar to the Alban counter gambit
except for it's on the Kings side so the
albumen counter gambit for those who who
haven't seen it before is in this normal
position
the movie 5 which the same sort of point
when they take you push and now you
can't play Knight to c3 though it's a
little bit different when you play it in
this move order because it's on the
kingside which can mean more dangers for
white especially you always have to be
looking out for this check but as long
as you have g3 then usually er you're
doing fine
we'll also show a game where rangas
Carlson was playing white and his
opponent took on f4 which is another
good way for black to try to equalize
the position but I will even look very
briefly here first at the more
aggressive way for black to play the way
to really confuse you if you've never
seen this before in this position
c6 so this is the nimzowitsch counter
defense the nimzowitsch
okay so it's it's a little bit different
and now suddenly everybody is confused
so this is a if you haven't seen it
before it's really hard to navigate
these paths so if you're this is a good
way to play as black because if your
opponent doesn't know what to do here
it's very very easy to make mistakes
because I don't know who would even play
the right move here as white well this
will make some wrong moves first so we
can understand because if there's a lot
of pawns that can take each other or you
could just develop your pieces it's very
tricky taking here is the worst why is
it the worst all right Queen to h4 let's
not forget about that and then okay so
yeah if I go here you're going here and
if I go here
Bishop to g4 okay and you let me go here
you're normally throwing this check in
it's gonna be strung and then you can
throw this one in too and then I can
block or I can go here and you can just
like keep laughing at me so yeah this
one probably bad I mean okay we can take
this and other bad stuff might happen to
you so so that's usually not the way to
go okay for what about this this is also
a popular response not that it's the
best move but a lot of people play this
way and okay so black will take and
again you have to make all these tough
choices so you can't really take on e5
so you can play Bishop to b5 the point
is you see that you want to play this
move and okay here black should probably
take this but you need to also consider
this possible move that black has and
what's funny about this position is well
it's probably equal but it's complicated
now you can get away from with this
which even though after you take black
can throw this check in again in this
variation black has a pawn in the way so
it doesn't work as well so that's that's
another thing if there's something on e4
or something protecting e4 then this
Queen check usually doesn't work and
even if you did play this way this is
probably a bad move to play as black
because let's say you go all the way
back
now it's White's turn again and
development is going to mean more in
this position than having forced white
to play the weakening g3 move because
you're not going to be able to take
advantage of g3 if all of your pieces
are on the back rank so if you had more
pieces out then inducing g3 might be
advantageous but here it would be white
to move and he'd get his pieces though
okay but uh okay so instead okay you can
also play Bishop to b5 so that you can
play Knight to f3 without a hassle and
if they take normally black can play
moves like Bishop to d6 in these
positions with the idea of putting his
knight on e7 and from E 7 he can protect
his pawn if
necessary and he also is looking into
some of these squares in a lot of lines
so very often the night goes to e7 in
these lines rather than f6 though I mean
f6 also is a very decent square for a
night and okay you get a position like
this and and things are normal so this
is this is one possible variation all
right and let's let's go here again and
then we'll try to remember what we've
looked at already so we've kind of
looked at both captures this one is is
more playable but the most common move
for white here if he's trying to play
for an advantage and probably knows a
little bit of theory is the move Knight
to c3 and then again like there's so
many pawns that can take things that
it's really confusing if you're unaware
of what's going on the main move here is
to take on e4 if you take here white
will take on e5 and notice again if you
play Queen to h4 the knight is
protecting efore so it's not gonna work
out as well so Queen h4 g3 and white is
fine so instead then you can play this
aggressive move they can push you around
a little bit
alright so 94 and now Queen h4 still
doesn't work because you can play Knight
f2 or 90 to g3
so Queen to d5
and okay the most common move for white
again might be a surprise queen de - and
black should play Knight to c6
but let's blunder oh alright now what
should white play Knight f3 excellent so
if you go to e6 Knight takes d4 is good
and what did you play they go here
Knight d6 yeah and this is this is
pretty bad news for black here okay if
you have to move your your king
okay I mean I might be able to trade and
you have to worry about f7 and there's
all sorts of bad stuff happening here
and white is already winning so this
would be a mistake so you can play here
and you get this sort of position where
everybody's confused after Bishop to g4
and you get a position like this and it
turns out white is a little bit better
here but obviously you could play this
way and there's so many tricky things
you have to navigate to play this
variation then it makes it a very useful
weapon for people that are willing to
put in a little bit of time and study
the variations so let's look at now the
main line here so now this is what a the
way most players typically play and
after this move a move that also might
surprise you because you probably think
okay you take back on d5 but black can
also get on with development he doesn't
want to fall too far behind in
development and white can take now or he
can he can wait patiently and only when
it's it's forced he can capture and so
you get an interesting position we'll
just go a few more moves here and
everybody castles and you get a position
like this where White has a four to two
majority on the Queen side and black has
a four to two majority on the Kings side
so this is actually a typical pawn
structure that you get when you play
this opening so we'll see similar pawn
structures and the two games that we're
gonna look at in just a second here
which okay white spawns are a little bit
healthier and that none of them are
doubled and the d4 pond is a past pond
so that's definitely his trump
however the black king is a little bit
safer than the white king so when black
starts storming with his pawns it could
be a little bit more dangerous for white
but overall it should be that balanced
position which is a it's pretty good
news that even there's a lot of declined
variations in the King's gambit that are
very playable and give black a
reasonable position so you don't have to
accept if you don't want you could play
the fault bare counter gambit for
example and there's a lot of interesting
lines in there but I will jump to our
games now so this first game is a game
between Magnus Carlsen and Y huey who's
was 27:52 at the time the Chinese
Grandmaster and this was played in 2010
in the Kings tournament so that's why he
played the Kings gambit and what was
funny about this tournament - is that
Carlsen they asked him at the end like
why'd you play the Kings gambit he's not
known for that he's known for his
positional slow playing whatever and he
said okay I'm having a bad tournament
it's the fourth round he had like a half
out of three points or you know he
wasn't doing very well so he's played
the Kings gambit and then he won in this
game and so he's feeling pretty good and
then he went on to win the tournament by
two points so this game really turned
his whole tournament around okay and if
Carlsen can play this and you know play
against 27 hundreds in a legitimate
tournament okay anybody can can play
this and there are tournaments here and
okay
it was the fault pure counter gambit so
he took and now instead of c6 and
instead of the main line his opponent
took on f4 and this variation should be
about equal if you play the main line
it's just an equal way to play so you
have nothing really do for your hair as
black this is a great try for to
equalize the game and okay now black is
thinking about Queen to h4 so Knight to
f3 and
black play Knight to f6 and here white
has a lot of choices in this game he
chose Bishop to c4 which is not the most
cop popular move but he had probably
prepared something here
the most common way to play is Bishop to
b5 in this way you make sure you get
this pawn and again you'll get a
situation where it's a four on two
versus a four on two and the main line
actually goes like this and okay so you
get a position like this where again
White has the healthier pawn structure
but black has the safer King and you
should have a rather balanced game later
in a blitz game in 2012 Carlsen in this
position preferred to move c4 in the
game went as follows so after c6 his
intention was never to take because then
no d4 would be really weak but he played
d4 and after the capture he played c5
and when you play Magnus Carlsen and he
has a majority on one side and you have
a majority on the other he does this and
like everybody Queens and then you lose
that's that seems to be what happens and
that's what happened in this game and
it's what happened in the game that
we're looking at today so he when he has
a majority me and he's really good at
pushing his majority okay so in this
game Bishop to c4 and black took this
bond okay White Castle Bishop to e7 and
now a controversial move he played a
move that's very surprising he took on
d5 which is not to eat the most popular
way to play but when Carlsen plays it
he's got some ideas the most popular
move here is d4 and we should look at
the mainline just so we can compare it
to what actually happens in the game so
here castles and only now do you take
and you can pick up the pawn and then
gain a tempo on the Queen so you know
very standard black has the two bishops
but white is a little bit ahead in
development and uh you know he's gonna
try to move his his pastures on the
queenside instead in this game he took
on d5
so black takes back and now he wins a
tempo on the Queen okay so he went back
and d4 now we could Castle or we could
play g5
I'll let the audience decide what would
you guys do in this position so if g5
this wasn't played in the game he
castled wait has a lot of normal moves
but I want to suggest a crazy move you
got it you know what it is Danny
yeah Knight takes g5 the craziest move
and then yeah the audience shaking their
heads hi everybody's confused okay so
you just you're giving up a piece huh
and then in this position white cap
should play the novelty Queen to e1
which is different than what's been
played before Queen to e2 in that the
rook here is protecting the Queen we'll
see why that's important in a second so
here you can either play a move like
King to f8 which is probably your your
best chance here and after some moves
like this we'll have at least two ponds
and we'll have lots of pressure down the
F file so it should be enough
compensation for white also interesting
is if they play here in this position
you can just take on f4 and now you'll
see why we Ronnie won so if they ever
take our Queen our rook swings in so
it's it's two pawns for the piece but if
we imagine this position which could
happen
white ends up getting a lot of pressure
here for example Knight to d5 and if you
protect your pawn otherwise I'm gonna
take and when your rook Knight to f6 and
black can maybe hold this position
together but this looks like a really
hard task because you can't develop your
Bishop it's hard to move any of your
pieces so what should have compensation
here for the piece just based on how
if his pieces are there's not even that
many pieces on the board but this should
be good for white but okay so he didn't
play g5 and allow any crazy stuff that
Carlson may have worked on at home
he just castled the practical choice so
white gets the pawn and now it's four on
three versus a three on two
okay and there's no double pawns in this
this game alright okay so he developed
white gets his queen out of the way he's
gonna put his rooks on d1 and e1 the
Queen might go to f2 where she's off the
opening file and excuse me here black
made an interesting decision one of
blacks Trump's in this position is the
two bishops but he decided to play the
move Bishop to d6 which is sort of a big
inaccuracy he's giving away one of his
his biggest advantages instead he might
want to consider c6 and then he can
maneuver his knight around and just sort
of and play the position with c6 here
but he decides to trade the bishops and
Carlsen doesn't mind okay so now you no
longer have the two bishops and I've
seen Carlsen he's had this position in
like a couple times usually in blitz
this was the only standard game I could
find where he played that the King's
gambit pony plays a Kings gambit
he gets the fall career counter gambit
like every time for some reason so very
very interesting and here his problem is
he wants to play the move c4 and get his
four-on-three rolling so in general
that's gonna be the plans the 4m3 is
gonna roll in the three on two you want
your majorities to go down the board
because then you can make a queen so
here he played Knight to be five so that
after the Queen moved he could play c4
and then black can kick the knight back
and the night will just go back to c3
and he also did something interesting
there's two ways to do it and he chose
a6 which okay it's probably fine but
later he might have
but he played c6 so we get this position
and it's okay not a whole lot going on
you know but this is sort of the
positions Carlson is best at he likes
this he positions where there's sort of
a slight imbalance and he slowly out
plays his opponents and okay so he
brings his rook over and the bishop gets
off the F file so we we get this
position here and all right things are
just going smoothly there's nothing
nothing a whole lot to say here and now
it's funny so he's he's going really
really slow magnus carlsen style and
then I guess his opponent didn't know
what to do because he made a strange
move here so who can play like a 2700
probably only Danny Machuca could play
such a strange move yeah I knew he could
do it yeah rook to c8 threatening
nothing so it's it's not like you're
gonna play c5 cuz then I just play d5 so
I think he's just like waiting he's like
what are you gonna do and alright so
sort of a strange move that doesn't do
anything and okay so he traded some
Brooks and now he plays the move c6
alright and he pushes his pawn so he's
gonna create a passer and that's so the
rest of the games started gonna revolve
around him pushing his passer and
whether or not he can do it so I could
very easily take on d5 in this moment
but he waited giving white the option of
taking on c6 if he wants but he decided
to okay I'll just play Queen d4 and I'll
let you trade and in this position you
can take with the pawn or the night and
perhaps he calculated and then he took
with his Knight so after this trade he
must have seen this position and
evaluated that this pawn is good and he
likes the knight first bishop in this
position and we'll try to understand why
so black black'
and now he needs to find a way to push
the spawn which means he needs to attack
the d6 square so hopefully you can you
can figure out what he did with his
knight here so he played Knight to e5
the point is you can play Knight to c4
and then you can push your pawn and if
you ever play a move like b5 you're
gonna give up the c6 square so if you if
you play here occasionally the knight
will be able to jump into this square
though not immediately because of rook
takes Knight but okay so black played
here now you can't play Knight to c4 so
I went here so he can play Knight to c4
and now what did white play he played
Knight to c4 that's what he wanted to do
so notice that this is not a very good
move White's not just hanging his pawn
what would you play here you Queen takes
all right that's good that's much better
than what was suggested before which is
here somebody suggested that and then
they get your rook so I just didn't
suggest that but yeah better is just
winning the Queen outright because you
can't take the Queen because of the back
rank okay so he went here giving you the
chance to double his pawns but he's
played instead rook to e5 keeping the
the Queen's on the board you can also
take here this is the bad news for black
is that this ending is also very good
for white if you take you still have the
two-on-one and this also is good for
white but his move is perhaps even
stronger rook to e5 and he's ready to
push his pawn so after some rules he
pushed and all right so he says he keeps
trying to get controlled the next square
he needs to go to and then a typical
Carlsen style he doesn't he doesn't do
anything for a long time he's just very
very slow improvements so he pushes a
four he's gonna play a five just cement
his knight there but now after g6 he
plays a tricky move Queen to c3
threatening rook takes a six and then if
you take the Queen we can throw this
check in before we take back here so he
protected this queen and very soon black
found it very hard to move you can't
really move this bishop anywhere over
here because of Knight to d5 and then if
a Queen moves so there's gonna be some
discoveries it's hard you can't really
move your rook you can't really move
your queen maybe you could play King to
g8 but he'd had enough and he decides to
sacrifice all right so this gets rid of
his problems and then you get this
ending
which is not very easy to win I mean
it's not like this is the easiest ending
in the world but he defends his pawn and
then he decides to trade the Queens so
you get an ending where it's black has a
pawn for the exchange but White has a
strong plan of just centralizing his his
King here and then this was the final
mistake Black has to sort of do nothing
but okay with the king coming in here
and infiltrating on the Queen side it's
kind of hard to to you know come up with
something but he did something and okay
now the game was almost over after the
move g4 will kind of go quickly through
this but okay this pawn went down the
board and here you okay he just pushed
his pawn what's funny too is even if you
take this and you say AHA I got all
these three passed pawns you really
don't have much if you ever play here
then King F - you ever play here we can
just like mop up stuff and you're a long
ways from making a threat which is kind
of surprising but the more you look at
it the more you'll realize just black
can't do anything and White's just gonna
play b5 and then make another Queen over
here so that's why he didn't he didn't
even try that so you let him Queen and
alright one last little trick
the problem is y can probably even take
the bishop and allow black to Queen on
f1 but why would you do that and okay so
here he resigned because even if even if
you Queen let's let's go ahead and get
Queen probably here this looks pretty
good okay cuz I'm yeah if you go here
then at least rook f7 but okay yeah
doesn't look like you're gonna you're
gonna live for very long so very
instructive games by Carlsen about how
to use your majority he got a past pond
he was able to fight for the squares
that he needed to advance his pawn and
okay all in all a really well played
game by him and it helped him he went on
and then he won
that tournament so yeah he's pretty good
but now we'll come on to the main line
of the default prayer counter gambit
does this say how much time we got 23
minutes all right I think we can do it
okay so we come back to this position
and now we will focus on the main line
here efore and this is okay so again
black has given up a pawn to make it
really hard for white to develop his
pieces so what's best move is to fight
against the thorn pawn on e4 with the
move d3 dimplex shouldn't take on d3 and
help white develop you should play
Knight to f6 and if white gets rid of
that pawn he takes and the main move
here if you develop so yeah Queen h4 was
a threat black plays here and then you
get worried if you've never seen this
before it's white it looks really scary
you know these pieces are coming in
maybe he's gonna play something to f2
bishop or Knight they both look a little
bit scary poet has this move Queen to e2
and black should play Bishop to f5 if
you play Bishop to f2 very tempting I
mean why not black is actually losing
people are shaking their heads like they
know this position yeah smart audience
tonight okay so after King to d1 I mean
okay I'm gonna I take this this looks
pretty good but what is White's winning
move here you better play play the right
move so blacks taking your stuff your
kings on d1 but you do have some
pressure on the e-file that night is
still pinned but here you have to play
the right move
okay so this seems like right the most
logical move you could make but actually
here black would just probably cement as
his piece here and Jack mania you can't
even take this night would be much
better on c3 but okay you can't play
that because you're in check so the
winning move is Knight - D - but it's
the other one this way you know okay so
you attack the knight on e4 and you can
attack it again with Knight to c3 so
this time if you sum enter your knight
in there Knight to c3 and after your
your Queen moves you can take this so
you better take back and okay so instead
of just taking that even better is
inserting the move c3 the Queen has to
stay where she's protecting the bishop
on f2 so the most common is Queen to e3
and you could trade some stuff and take
your efore pawn back but even stronger
is Queen to h5 okay and after they move
Bishop c4 you're threatening a checkmate
and let's say black sees it the the
crushing move here is Queen to d5 so
you're threatening checkmate and Knight
takes e4 and so white should have a
decisive winning position here
especially you got some pressure coming
down the heat at the F file pretty soon
here okay so this this actually should
be completely winning for white but okay
if you haven't seen this before and you
just you run into this position is black
it does look tempting right bishop to f2
a very tempting move but not a good one
instead you should protect your knight
and it may appear that this was a
blunder because I see people going
so it looks like a blender because what
if they just play g4 so this is gonna be
the game that we're gonna look at in
just a second a game between Spielman
and tirage that was played in 1923 but
first let's look at the main line
a more common move for white is just to
develop Knight to c3 and this often
leads to an endgame
so we're threatening to win on something
on e4 here and after this there's two
different end games that black can go
into but Lulu is like looking at her
watch so we'll only go over one of them
the most common one is to take on e3 and
then trade everything and you get this
endgame and actually white should be
better in this endgame this isn't
something white should be afraid of here
okay you're probably tempted to take on
c2 but more common for black is to play
Bishop to e4 figuring either I'm gonna
double your pawns or I'm gonna win your
D pawn which is more important than your
CC pawns and it does look at first sight
like okay so material is is about to be
equal when black gets as his pawn back
here and okay White's position is a
little shattered so maybe this is better
for black well that's actually not the
case in this position white can get a
lot of activity that will more than
compensate for the damaged pawn
structure that he has here with a move
like Knight to g5 and okay you're gonna
take and now we Castle and okay so the
most common move is c6 but you're
probably wondering what happens if you
take here and the problem is the move c4
and the bishop is is starting to get
trapped you can try to get out of this
bind but among whites good moves he can
just develop and alright there's there's
several lines if you take with the
bishop for example we'll see in a lot of
lines the large loss of activity you
can't usually can't go back here because
okay you can see whoops well fine we'll
do
check me so you can see white gets a lot
of activity and so if you can force the
King to f6 well you you know I mean you
have threats here you know you have all
sorts of threats that are coming in and
White's position is so active that it's
actually bad news for black I guess
we'll go over one more line okay well
and again King f6 cuz if here you can
take here threatening checkmate in the
bishop so yeah you can kind of get an
idea that something like this is really
bad for black so you can't really take
this pawn so first this will speed
through this one more time so let's be
sort of the starting point and white
will usually attack the H pawn and bring
this other piece in and it's pieces are
very very active which is more important
in this position than the fact that your
C pawns are doubled okay but let's get
back to our featured game here so we'll
go all the way back alright so after
this Bishop f5 in the yeah the game
Spielman tirage the blunder g4 was
played but I want to give the audience a
chance to figure out what black should
play here it looks good you know you
move your bishop away and I'll take your
knight and I'll be so happy so this was
the first recorded game with this
position and black found the best move
so since then this has been the most
common move and so since people know
this this game I guess if you play this
variation they know the best move here
for black is simply to castle which is a
bit shocking right I'm you know okay I
just thank you but what was black
intending to play here rook to e8 and
this thread along the e-file is already
very bad news for white so white here is
is flirting with a very lost position
what's nice about this game is for a
long time white played all the best
defensive moves but he still lost so
this is this is good for black he tried
Bishop to G - alright computer computer
likes it it was fine
Knight to have to
and okay losing your queen is the most
important thing here let's not lose our
queen
so you went here and you lost in
exchange here and it's very easy to make
a mistake here as black it's very easy I
think most people would would not play
the best move here
epps six not the best move but very
tempting right just okay right you want
to attack the pins peace with your
weakest thing but this allows a
brilliant repartee for white in the move
d6 and okay you intend here for example
if you take this we can check and after
you go back we can take here and white
might be able to survive in a position
like this so the worst is sort of over
for white obviously his King is still
weak so he does have to be really
careful but he didn't you know like lose
material here as much as he would in the
main line so so d6 a very very sneaky
you know thing that the white has going
for him and I suppose black must have
seen it because he played the better
move Knight to d7 and you're argh so
after some developing now f6 so your
Bishop is protected now the point of
Knight to d7 is to protect your Bishop
okay he
I know I thought you're gonna like no no
okay
so we got these trades and yay look six
connected pass pause yeah yeah here I go
all my pawns and then white made a lot
of Queens okay here your King is a bit
weak and black black played pretty well
here so the check is good and then
there's a lot of things but okay this
move is good and then you can easily
take on f5 that's a good move but he
played trickier he went here check and
then he took the central pawn so really
kicking the legs out of all the pawns
that might have done this to him and
then he can continue to play the best
but the trickiest so well we'll go
through it as fast as we can here so
there's a paint on the e-file so we
can't really move our bishop so he
unpinch this way and alright so the
Queen might be coming in to d2 he stops
that and then here white makes the final
mistake that really kills him here he
takes this night and this is you know
this is a blunder that really cost the
game it was already very very bad for
white it was probably already losing but
this opening the G file just gives black
access to the King and there's there's
nothing that can be done here so we'll
be playing h3 x lamb h3 h3 and then here
he resigned well yeah I mean I guess if
you go here
sadly the best move is just to take the
Queen you know like you're not checkmate
wait darn in something like this also I
mean if you're letting the Queen come in
some but also I might just take this and
I might take this like everything's
hanging yeah you can't really run away
because we have here so the game is
almost over so yeah white gave it up h3
didn't help him out I guess
it's closed good great move but also I
mean what else do you even play I mean
hmm okay so that's a little introduction
so next week we'll accept the gambit and
we'll we'll do the main main line or
maybe we'll just do the Kings gambit for
like the next few months maybe we'll
never stop because the first I said all
right we're just gonna do two then I
told you three maybe next week okay
we're gonna do four five we're just
gonna never stop doing the Kings gambit
so thanks to a Lulu for filling in for
Ben Simon she did fantastic
thank you good please hit like share
subscribe and we'll see you guys next
time thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]